it's a sort of purgatory day night it
makes no difference in their thousands
they just have to wait
and they're sleeping rough hoping for
news
hoping they can get into the system a
system that will get them out of
afghanistan the truth is
most of them probably won't
thousands of children parents and
grandparents grabbing sleep or basically
passing out from exhaustion
the struggle never stops
no food little water
but it is cooler at night
when the sun comes up the true horror of
the conditions they're living in is
obvious
and it is absolutely dreadful they're
penned in this is the american section
of the processing chain
higher security alerts means there's no
movement allowed
there is no shade here only what can be
fashioned from scarves and plastic
soldiers slowly try to work through the
paperwork of the evacuees but the
conditions are getting stricter and more
and more are failing the test of
eligibility
but for everyone here even these awful
conditions are better than what may
await them outside the military lines
outside this taliban is kicking the
people with a rifle with everything i
put in it i put i put in a wood with a
for with the people you kind of check
him outside his taliban is
very fighting with the people
at the british end of the process the
taliban and paratrooper cooperation is
actually working quite well
you couldn't make this up taliban
fighters oversee the crowds from sea
containers that paris put in to create a
screening barrier
well it's an incongruous site having the
taliban right next to it in fact through
the british lines
you can see in front it's much calmer
here
the british military
are able to process people and i think
what they've done
is got the message through to the local
people if you're rioting and shouting
and screaming and people are getting
hurt there's no way that this can be
processed properly so for now at least
it's calm i mean
there'll be anxiety it'll change it
always does
but uh this is a lot better yesterday a
lot better
containing the crowds is vital here
clearing up this evacuation mess
requires some pretty lateral thinking
obviously after 20 years of fighting
this is something of a culture shock for
the soldiers but also for the taliban
the main thing for us is to make sure
that we have a smooth possible system to
get those entitled people through
and um at the moment that that involves
an element of the taliban um being here
alongside as you would have seen while
you've been here and ultimately we have
our thoughts of
previous tours aside because ultimately
everybody is trying to get the same
situation here which to us avoid a
humanitarian crisis and bring those
people through immediately but it's just
not the strangest thing
strange times strange times
but like i say
if we weren't here
you know who would be you know we it
needs to be done
and
as you said
everybody's feeling it but ultimately
you put that to one side and get on with
the job
this is now a multi-national nightmare
not just the us and britain
in the crowds they try to identify
themselves to the soldiers and foreign
services of countries they have links to
their days are spent hoping someone will
spot them and take them out of this hell
hole and onto a plane
the wait is often days and days
in the horrendous rush to get here
families have been split
posters for missing children are dotted
amongst the crowds
people search for their loved ones in a
days of panic
but this is a tough environment only a
few will make the flights only some will
go as a complete family and nobody knows
how long they have
it is purgatory
ramsay sky news kabul